>> Nicole: WELCOME BACK.
LET'S GET TO THE 2020 ROUND UP.
SUPPORTERS OF JOE BIDEN ARE
MAKING THE CASE THEY CAN REACH
ACROSS THE PARTISAN DIVIDE.
YOU KNOW, HERE I AM.
I KNOW THAT I HEAR THAT HE IS A
REPUBLICAN DAD.
I UNDERSTAND, ONE OF MY FAVORITE
REPUBLICAN DADS, JOHN KASICH WHO
WAS THE FORMER GOVERNOR OF OHIO,
HE THINKS JOE BIDEN CAN REACH
ACROSS THE AISLE.
NICOLE, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Nicole: I DON'T KNOW WHAT A
REPUBLICAN DAD IS.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS ODD.
I WILL SAY AND I SAID BEFORE ON
THE SHOW THAT I THINK THE
NEVER TRUMPERS WOULD BE MORE
INCLINED TO VOTE FOR BIDEN IF
BIDEN WAS ON THE TICKET.
IF YOU HAD ELIZABETH WARREN ON
THE TICKET.
I THINK NEVER TRUMPERS MAY NOT
SHOW UP TO VOTE.
I PERSONALLY THINK IT WOULD
BEHOOVE THEM TO PUT A MORE
MODERATE DEMOCRAT ON THEIR
TICKET.
>> Capri: MICHAEL, ARE YOU
BUYING WHAT SHE'S SELLING.
>> Michael: NO.
NO REPUBLICAN IS GOING TO VOTE
FOR BIDEN AND CERTAINLY NOT
WARREN.
HAVING THE ENDORSEMENT OF
JOHN KASICH, MY DAD WAS A
POSTMAN.
I AM A BUCKEYE.
I AM FROM COLUMBUS.
I HAVE A PERSONAL ANIMOSITY.
JOHN KASICH --
>> Capri: IT'S NOT THE
JOHN KASICH DEBATE.
IT'S THE BIDEN DEBATE.
>> Michael: THIS IS THE
DEMOCRATS' CHRISTMAS WISH.
PLEASE LET THERE BE REPUBLICANS
WILL VOTE FOR BIDEN.
>> Capri: DO YOU THINK ANYONE
CAN GET THE REPUBLICAN DAD VOTE?
>> Dana: I THINK IS MISGUIDED.
THERE'S PROBABLY A TOTAL OF 200
OF THESE POSSIBLE VOTES IN THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY OF THREE AND A
35 MILLION PEOPLE.
THE IDEA THAT THERE ARE A BUNCH
OF NEVER TRUMPERS LEFT, DOESN'T
EXIST.
IT'S A FANTASY.
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA CLING TO
IT.
IT DOESN'T EXIST.
THERE MIGHT BE AT A FEW.
IF THEY IT'S A REPUBLICAN MOMS,
I THINK THAT MIGHT BE MORE
DOABLE FOR SOMEONE LIKE BIDEN
BECAUSE OF THE SUBURBAN VOTE.
LET'S SAY YOU WILL YOU HAVE A
DEBATE ON POLICY, IT'S NOT THAT
HE'S THAT CONSERVATIVE OR
MODERATE.
HIS POLICIES ARE ACTUALLY QUITE
PROGRESSIVE.
>> Capri: DO YOU THINK JESSE
THAT THERE IS A RUNNING MATE HE
CAN PICK IF BIDEN IS THE NOMINEE
THAT THERE'S A RUNNING MATE?
[LAUGHTER]
GET SOMEONE SUCH AS YOURSELF FOR
EXAMPLE.
>> Jesse: I WOULD BE AN
UNREASONABLE REPUBLICAN DAD
BECAUSE I HAVE NEVER VOTED FOR
JOE BIDEN NEVER AND I THINK HE'S
AIMING AT THE WRONG SLICE OF THE
ELECTORATE.
HE HAS A PROBLEM ON HIS LEFT
WING.
HE NEEDS TO SHORE UP THE LEFT
WING BEFORE HE STARTS CROSSING
OVER FOR THESE INDEPENDENT,
REASONABLE REPUBLICANS.
TRUMP HAS A 90% APPROVAL RATING
AMONG REPUBLICANS.
IF THEY DO GO HEAD-TO-HEAD IN
GENERAL, I THINK TRUMP WINS MORE
REASONABLE DEMOCRAT DADS THEN
BIDEN WINS ON THAT SIDE.
>> Capri: IT'S A BILLIONAIRE
MEDIA BLITZ.
2020 DEMOCRAT MICHAEL BLOOMBERG
AND TOM STEYER HAVE BEEN
SATURATING THE AIRWAVES BY
SPENDING NEARLY $200 MILLION
COMBINED SO FAR ON POLITICAL AD
ADS.
DANA, YOU KNOW THAT A LOT OF THE
SOCIALISTS IN MY PARTY ARE NOT
HUGE FANS OF BILLIONAIRES.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GOING TO BE --
IS IT GOING TO BE HELD AGAINST?
>> Dana: HAVE TO WALK A LITTLE
BIT OF A TIGHT ROPE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T LIKE THEM COMING IN THE
RACE.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG WAS ABLE TO
BUY'S WING AND HIT 5% WITHOUT
HAVING TO DO ANY LEGWORK THAT
THE REST OF THEM ARE DOING.
I THINK THERE'S PROBABLY SOME
RESENTMENT.
THEY ALSO NEED HIS MONEY.
HE'S BEEN ABLE TO FLIP A STATE
LIKE VIRGINIA.
IT'S A BIG DEAL IF YOU WANT THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
I ALSO THINK IF YOU LOOK AT THE
GOVERNOR OF ILLINOIS, HE WAS
RUNNING AGAINST THE INCUMBENT
GOVERNOR AND HE WAS PRETTY ON
POPULAR.
HE WON IN THE END I KNOW HE'S
THE GOVERNOR OF ILLINOIS.
IT'S NOT UNPRECEDENTED.
HARDER TO DO ON THE NATIONAL
LEVEL.
>> Michael: HOW DO YOU KNOW
ALL THESE NAMES?
>> Dana: THE EARLY BIRD GETS
THE WORM, MICHAEL.
>> Capri: EXPERIENCED AND
EFFECTIVE.
MAYBE SHE HAS FLASH CARDS.
NICOLE, DANA BRINGS UP A GOOD
POINT.
THERE HAD BEEN SOME SUCCESSES OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO DO MUCH SELF
FINANCED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A BILLION ARE
TOO AND HE GOT DEMOCRATS --
>> Nicole: HE DIDN'T SELL FUND
ALL OF HIS CAMPAIGN.
>> Capri: I AM TALKING ABOUT
BILLIONAIRE VERSUS BILLIONAIRE.
DEMOCRATS SAY THEY DON'T LIKE
BILLIONAIRES BUT THERE ARE
DEMOCRATS THAT VOTED FOR A
BILLIONAIRE IN DONALD TRUMP.
DO YOU THINK THOSE SAME PEOPLE
MIGHT SEE SOME ONE LIKE
BLOOMBERG IS SOMEONE THEY CAN
VOTE FOR?
>> Nicole: MAY BE.
I WANT TO GET BACK TO TOM STEYER
FOR A SECOND.
HE'S WORTH $1.6 BILLION IN IT HE
PULLED IN LESS THAN 2%.
ONE OF HIS BIG PLANS, IF HE
WANTS TO PAY FARMERS TO LESSEN
THEIR CARBON EMISSIONS.
THAT'S A BIG THING FOR HIM.
GUESS WHAT HE CAN DO IT THAT
$80 MILLION.
WHY DOESN'T HAVE A PRIVATE
FUNDING OF THESE FARMERS TO
LESSEN THE CARBON EMISSIONS.
DO SOMETHING FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> Capri: I AM ALL FOR
INVESTING IN ANAEROBIC
DIGESTER'S.
MICHAEL, DO YOU BELIEVE IN
ANAEROBIC DIGESTER'S?
>> Michael: ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S HOW I LIVE MY LIFE.
I LIKE THE AD AGENCIES.
THAT'S THE BUSINESS I WANT TO BE
IN.
THE GUY WHO GOES IN, YOU GO TO
BLOOMBERG AND TOM STEYER AND YOU
SAY YOU NEED MORE ADS.
YOU CAN DO IT.
>> Capri: DO YOU THINK THE
TOM STEYER IMPEACHMENT ADS HAVE
MOVED ANYBODY?
>> Jesse: I FEEL BAD FOR
PEOPLE IN THESE EARLY STATES WE
NEED TO SEE THEM ON TV EVERY
TIME THEY TURN ON THE
TELEVISION.
$200 MILLION, A LOT OF WINE
CAVES.
A LOT OF CAVES AND A LOT OF
WINE.
I ADDED UP.
BLOOMBERG IS WORTH $56 BILLION.
IF HE IS SPENDING 200 MILLION,
WE WILL ROUND UP, YOU KNOW HOW
MUCH THAT IS?
.3% OF HIS NET WORTH.
THAT'S THE AVERAGE PERSON WHO
MAKES 50,000 A YEAR SPENDING
$178 ON A POLITICAL --
>> Capri: PEOPLE WHO AREN'T
DOWN WITH SOCIALISTS, THE REAL
QUESTION IS THE BERN BACK?
DEMOCRATIC INSIDERS REPORTEDLY
TAKING BERNIE SANDERS VERY
SERIOUSLY AFTER INITIALLY
WRITING THEM OFF IN THIS 2020
ELECTION CYCLE.
SOME ARE SAYING AND THEY ARE
SEEKING
TAEKING
TAKIING
TAKINGG
TAKING A SECOND LOOK, SAYING
THAT BERNIE COULD OUTRIGHT WIN
DENOMINATION.
I'M NOT ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE.
I DO NOT THINK BERNIE SANDERS
GOING TO WIN THE NOMINATION.
DANA.
>> Dana: I THINK HE HAS A
LITTLE BIT OF A NEW LEASE ON
LIFE.
HE HAS A HEART ATTACK.
HE GOT THE AOC ENDORSEMENT.
SHE'S BEEN CAMPAIGNING FOR HIM.
BECAUSE THE EARLY STATES ARE NOT
WIN OR TAKE ALL AND IS
PROPORTIONAL, HE COULD POSSIBLY
GET THERE BUT THE REPUBLICANS
WOULD LIKE NOTHING BETTER.
>> Capri: I TEND TO AGREE.
MICHAEL.
DO YOU FEEL THE BERN?
>> Michael: I DON'T.
I THINK BERNIE IS THE ONLY ONE
IN THE FIELD IT'S THE LEAST BIT
AUTHENTIC.
HE GENUINELY BELIEVES THE BSE
SELLING.
>> Nicole: I FEEL THE BERN BUT
IT MIGHT BE INDIGESTION.
HE'S NOT VERY VOCAL IN THE
MEDIA.
I HOPE THINK HE'S GOING TO BE
THE NOMINEE.
>> Capri: JESSE, THE FINAL
WORD.
>> Jesse: I THINK HE COULD
FORCE HIS WAY ONTO A TICKET, A
UNITY TICKET LIKE DANA SAID.
NO ONE'S GOING TO HIT THRESHOLD.
THEY GET TO THE BACK ROOM IN
MADISON, WISCONSIN, AND HE GETS